foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the 2022 U.S and U.S women's
Chess Championship
please welcome executive director of the
St Louis chess club Tony Rich
hello everyone and welcome to the
opening ceremony for the 2022 U.S Chess
Championship and the 2022 U.S women's
Chess Championship I'm Tony Rich and I'm
the executive director of the St Louis
chess club and I would like to welcome
you all to St Louis
the U.S championships are events that we
hold in St Louis and we've been doing so
since 2009 over that time we've given
away millions of dollars in prize money
we've awarded national championship
titles to many of America's best men and
women and we look forward to doing so
again in about two weeks
the U.S championships are always our uh
bread and butter you know they're
they're really the events that we we've
come to love not just because they
represent uh Elite competition
uh it also represents some of the very
best chess players not just in the
country but in the world but more
importantly for us it's like family
coming back to St Louis so on behalf of
the St Louis chess club team and all the
staff I would like to say welcome home
to all the chess players
it's now my pleasure to introduce to you
uh one of the co-founders of the St
Louis chess club Dr Jeannie Karen
singfield has been responsible for such
Publications as learn to read and write
chess it's been translated now into lots
of languages I'm sure Genie how many how
many languages now
11 languages so this isn't just how to
play chess this is how we speak chess
it's how we read chess it's how to be
literate in the game of chess and we
need to be literate in order to be
professionals so Genie if you would do
us the honor of joining us on stage now
[Music]
well welcome to uh St Louis the chess
capital of America
so I I was I was thinking about the fun
stuff we've done here in the state to
make
the United States and the Missouri be
the chess capital
and I was looking back at Irena Crush I
was the one who taught the first chess
merit badge to any Scouts in America
and Irina Crush was the first one to
teach a test merit badge to girls when
they could first join Scouts to become
Eagle Scouts so that's out tyrena
so and I know I'm going to take a little
line around from
from
Mr Bauer and it's up to 250 000.
okay and I'm looking out in the audience
and that little booklet I wrote which is
available in 11 languages I want to
shout out to
Christian shurilla for translating it
into Romanian
and to Wesley so's family for getting
the translation into Filipino
I helped on the Indonesian
and
is Alejandro here I think he did Spanish
like it's funny 11 languages
so and for those of you the latest one
is Swahili anyway my job is to introduce
Rex so you're looking at me and thinking
what am I going to say now right
well
I do want you to know that
Rex's back sort of playing chess
with 16 games a day you know so not that
he's going to beat you but there's like
There's Hope
so I would like to introduce now as a
fairy godmother of the U.S chess the god
Godfather of American yes
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you Genie and welcome players
to the 2022 chess championships and
congratulations to the 2021 World Chess
Hall of Fame inductees and the 2022 U.S
Chess Hall of Fame inductees Jeannie and
I are thrilled
that the championships have a little
more meaning this year
given that U.S chess has moved their
headquarters to St Louis
congratulations and welcome
[Applause]
we wanted to hold this opening at Union
Station because U.S chess's new offices
are located in the building inside the
parking lot where you park this evening
it's nice to have the players meeting in
their offices to Showcase their new
location just before opening night
I would also like to mention that St
Louis is the site will be the site of
the 2022
World Series
[Applause]
I also want to mention that although we
have a variety of delays we have
received finally approval and permits
from the city of St Louis and will begin
starting construction in the near future
and will be growing from 6 500 square
feet to 30 000 square feet and plan to
hold 2023 U.S championships in the new
space
[Applause]
lastly I want to thank all of the staff
and vendors for putting on such a
wonderful evening in particular the
people who helped make everything run
every day to Joy Bray
where's Miss Joyce
well wherever she is she's running
things uh to Tony Rich Shannon Bailey
Emily Allred they all do a magnificent
job and all of the staff at each place
we couldn't do anything without you well
thank you all for attending tonight's
festivities and we look forward to
watching some very exciting chess over
the next few weeks and now I'll turn it
back to Tony I think
[Applause]
some of you attended the the opening
ceremony that we just had uh
at Forest Park we did it at the the
World's Fair Pavilion that's the word uh
and at the World's Fair Pavilion I had
the great honor of introducing the chief
curator of the World Chess Hall of Fame
unfortunately it was also mistaken in
reading my remarks and it wasn't her
turn to speak but I promise you it is
this time my counterpart at the World
Chess Hall of Fame the chief curator
Shannon Bailey
foreign
[Music]
it is such an honor to welcome all of
you to this wonderful event and this
fantastic St Louis venue I love this
place
um the World Chess Hall of Fame is
celebrating our 11th year here in St
Louis and we have our largest exhibition
on view Fisher spassky the match its
origin and influence influence it's
celebrating Fisher's win over Boris
baskey 50 years ago it not only looks at
that match but important events that
happen to both forests and Bobby before
and after that and that the impact that
that win had on American chess that we
are now all a part of tonight's event is
always so special because we get to
celebrate the newest inductees to the
prestigious U.S and World Chess Halls of
Fame in front of potentially many of the
next group of people being inducted
congratulations to all of you who are
being inducted tonight and best of luck
to all of you participating in the U.S
championships and thank you to the staff
and Rex and Genie for all your support
and that all that you do for American
chess
[Applause]
U.S chess is the sanctioning body for
chess in the United States in fact they
are responsible for awarding uh titles
like U.S Champion U.S junior Champion
U.S Senior champion and so on the St
Louis chess club submits a bid every
year to U.S chess requesting the
privilege to host the Championship
events and since 2009 we've been lucky
and honored to to host them right here
in our hometown
uh the executive director of U.S chess
Carol Meyer has been with the
organization now for a number of years
and in that time uh she has seen the
relocation as we all just found out of
U.S chess to St Louis
um and uh that is why I wear my St Louis
flag pin tonight instead of my U.S chess
pin so without further Ado executive
director Carol Meyer
good evening everyone I'm so happy to be
here welcoming you to our new home here
in St Louis
as as we prepared for this evening's
opening ceremony the great team at the
World Chess Hall of Fame and at
Silverback helped us put together a
slideshow which I think may be running
behind me to highlight the amazing chess
history that St Louis has
some highlights of that history
1886 the first official world
championship event
1904 the seventh American chess Congress
took place in St Louis and during the
World's Fair the the Masters chess
tournament at the Congress was won by
none other than Frank Marshall
there have been two U.S opens um 1941
and 1960 almost a couple years ago but
covet had other plans and the Western
chess Association
Western open took place here in 1904
which was the predecessor organization
to U.S chess
as Tony and others have mentioned the
U.S championships have been held here
since 2009 and in 2011 the World Champ
World Chess Hall of Fame relocated to St
Louis
2014 the U.S Senate proclaimed that St
Louis is the chess capital of the United
States
and in 2022 the U.S chess executive
board
um
basically mentioned that it would it was
its intention to relocate the
organization to St Louis and in August
we were officially moved here having
vacated and sold our building in
Crossville Tennessee
the recent St Louis chess activities
would not have been possible without Dr
Jeannie and Rex singfield
the Hall of Fame and all they do to make
chess a visible focal point for everyone
both in the United States and abroad
we're proud to call St Louis our home
and we look forward to being part of all
the chess excitement available here in
this great City moving forward
best of luck to all the players over the
next few weeks as you become the next
you as you play to become the next U.S
champion thank you
[Applause]
and on behalf of Carol Meyer it's my
privilege to introduce you to the
president of U.S chess Randy Bauer
foreign
so thank you I'm really pleased to be
here and as
many have already said we're really
pleased to be in St Louis this is truly
the U.S chap chess capital of the United
States the U.S Senate has told us so and
and we know it from all the activity
that's been going on here so on behalf
of the 85 000 members of U.S chess I'd
like to thank Dr Jeannie and Rick
singfield for their extreme generosity
in support of both U.S chess and the U.S
chess championships
hmm
I'd also like to thank the St Louis
chess club as has been mentioned before
in particular Joy Bray Tony Rich who
jumped up to introduce me and then also
Shannon Bailey of the Chess Hall of Fame
because they all put an incredible
amount of time and effort into these
events and and they run so well and they
truly are the Envy of the chess national
championships in the rest of the world
huh
so I've told the story of kind of how
this began many times but I always like
to repeat it how Rex and I
um were at dinner discussing the city of
St Louis Finance study when the topic
turned to chess and I was on the
executive board at U.S Chess at the time
and as as has been mentioned that was
several quite a few years ago and Rex
told me about the chess club that he was
in the process of building in St Louis
and you know okay well that's great the
chess club we have lots loads and lots
of cities and after dinner he took me on
a tour of it and I was blown away
because there so much about it the
physical space itself the surrounding
area the attention to detail that's just
unsurpassed in any other chess club in
the United States or maybe even in the
world
so Rex mentioned to me as we were doing
the tour that maybe sometime he'd like
to host a U.S championship and that
caught my attention because we were
looking at that time for a sponsor for
the U.S championship and I said well you
know Rex maybe that's something you'd
like to look into
um I I'm not a very good poker player he
probably could already tell that I was
very interested in that actually coming
to pass and when I got back to Des
Moines where I live the next day I made
two phone calls the first was to Jen
shahad shahadi who's been Rex's long
time chess coach and you know kind of
like Jenny was this a dream and you know
she assured me that no Rex was the real
deal so then I made a second call which
was to the USGS executive director at
the time and said you've got to get to
St Louis and you've got to meet with
Rex's people and he did and the rest
kind of is history since that point in
time the St Louis chess club put in a
bid and they've been awarded the U.S
Championship every year since that time
and the events as one who's attended
this event many times and attended U.S
championships before
um
Dr Jeannie and rexingfield started
putting you know their support behind it
it's just night and day in terms of what
this event is now and I suspect that
this year and years to come will be the
the best ever so in the last few years
as part of U.S chess leadership we've
noticed what's going on in St Louis and
we want to be a part of it we think this
is the place where chess is growing and
will continue to grow and we can build
on it so we moved our headquarters as
they've been mentioned several times in
the last couple of months and we're
really excited to be here I believe this
is now not just our home but our
permanent home and I feel the same way
about this championship and again I want
to thank Dr Jeannie and Rick singfield
so much for their support because I'm
hopeful that not only will we have a
permanent home here but the U.S
Championship will also have a permanent
Home in St Louis and thank you all for
being a part of this great event
[Applause]
you know for a long time I've said the
chess club teaches you how to play chess
in the Hall of Fame Hall of Fame teaches
you why you should play chess it's
interesting to me that
um my arts and culture side is a little
underdeveloped I'll have to say
um but what the World Chess Hall of Fame
has brought to St Louis is nothing short
of of amazing really because what it
does is it brings chess to people who
don't already play necessarily people
who maybe have some tangential
connection to the game but they have
always felt you know that's not for me
that's for somebody else I'm too
intimidated to go do that
um Emily Allred is the curator at the
World Chess Hall of Fame and she
probably knows more about certainly she
knows more about Chess history than I do
and in fact if I look around the room
here I can probably see just a couple of
folks who know a little bit more than
she does about it so the World Chess
Hall of Fame is in great hands uh with
curator Emily Allred
thank you
hi thank you all for being here
um I've been fortunate enough to work on
our annual inductions since about the
time that I started here and I've gotten
to see a lot of wonderful people be
inducted this is one of my favorite
events that we have every year because
it's part of our core Mission which is
to honor the game of chess and its
greatest players the world in U.S Chess
Hall of Fame inductions celebrate the
careers of the best International and
National players writers chess
supporters and other contributors to the
game
um it's a really special time since we
get to see all the players in the
Championships the people who are making
chess history right now while we're
celebrating the past
um last year we honored Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St Louis
chess campus Founders for their
contributions to the game
and then we also honored James Sherwin
and Frank Brady this year we'll be
honoring the 2022 U.S inductees and 2021
World inductees and we're fortunate
enough to have two of them here with us
this year Grandmaster Eugene ture and
Grandmaster James tarchan fide chooses
the newest inductees to the World Chess
Hall of Fame while the new inductees for
the U.S Chess Hall of Fame are selected
by the U.S chess recognitions committee
then confirmed by the U.S chess Trust
this year Al Lawrence the managing
director of the U.S chess trust will be
conducting tonight's inductions he's
been part of the Hall of Fame since its
beginning he was there when it was in
the basement of the U.S Chess Federation
headquarters in New Windsor New York I
hope that you'll enjoy tonight's evening
and that you'll come to the World Chess
Hall of Fame to learn a little bit more
about the game's best players
[Applause]
good evening
I wasn't going to tell this story but
since Randy told his story again
about how the Championships came to St
Louis
I want to tell how the the World Chess
Hall of Fame came to St Louis
it has a history that did start in a
basement in 1988
it was surrounded by supplies and
inventory it was a modest room but it
taught me over time that starts count a
lot
well it moved to several nice locations
in Miami was one
and we celebrated a lot of inductees
there
and then the sponsoring company they're
full and hard times and it was no longer
possible I was no longer there I was
back in my home office in New York and I
was getting calls from people
they said things like
what have you done with my capablanca
mementos they said it more threateningly
than that
and
I thought I have to you know I'm not
there anymore but they're calling me and
this is a a great cause I need to do
something about it who can I call so I
called Tony
I didn't know Rex I'm not going to call
Rex
so I called Tony and I said Tony do you
think Rex would be interested in also
having the World Chess Hall of Fame in
St Louis
he says I don't know I'll check
and in a whirlwind of activity
we moved everything from Storage to St
Louis
and
Rex built another building
right across the street
and that's how it came and I assure you
the U.S chess trust U.S chess and the
whole U.S chess community and the World
Chess Community owes a lot to the same
fields and we're we really appreciate it
so it's also a great honor for me to be
here tonight of course and and to do the
inductions in to the two different Halls
that are housed there one is the U.S
Chess Hall of Fame and we'll do that
first
and then the World Chess Hall of Fame
now the world's just Hall of Fame I I uh
I I know Emily explained the U.S Chess
Hall of Fame and who who decides on that
and it is a series of uh people
beginning with some very learned chess
historians
who
um specialize in different periods of
chess
the World Chess Hall of Fame
we didn't really have permission to do
that until 2001 that was something that
happened in Miami
where fide granted
U.S trust trust the right to have the
one and only World Chess Hall of Fame
also housed with the U.S Chess Hall of
Fame so that's that's the history of how
these World buildings these World
offices came to to the U.S and to St
Louis
you'll see me use you'll see me use a
special gamble tonight
it's this one
and it's a specially designed gavel by
the World Chess Hall of Fame staff
that honors our longtime U.S chess trust
president and former U.S chess
president Carol Winston so we'll bang in
our inductees with this gavel
some people
actually tonight
waited a long time on a bus to get to
the to get to the induction of the World
Chess Hall of Fame but here's a funnel
that waited a lot longer
he's the one from the past we do look
back to the past and bring people into
the U.S Chess Hall of Fame as well
and his name is Daniel Willard
Fisk
and he's quite possibly the most
scholarly of all the inductees
he spoke and taught
German
in Swedish
I was looking to see if they play played
me off the stage like they do at the
Academy Awards
he spoke German and taught German
Swedish Icelandic and even Persian at
Cornell
he directed the very first University
press in America there
he famously served as a librarian at
Cornell he also served as the General
Secretary of the American geographical
Society
really a sort of 19th century
Renaissance Man
do we have a picture there he is
now I'd like to tell
one inside story about him he graduated
at Hamilton from Hamilton College in the
1840s it's just a few hours from where I
now live in the New York State Hudson
Valley
and I want you to look at his picture
and then I want you to realize that he
was once Young
and when he was a sophomore at Hamilton
College he was kicked out for a prank
I've often tried to find out the details
of that prank
that this mind would come up with to get
kicked out of Hamilton College
now as far as chance he was a seminal
person in American chess
he organized and made the 1857 American
chess Congress a reality and without
that you know that was that was
basically the Forerunner of what's going
to have start happening tomorrow with
the American championship
and without that most of us would never
have heard
of the first inductee into the U.S Chess
Hall of Fame Paul Murphy because he
invited Paul Murphy to play in that
tournament and morphe won it and went on
to there to basically
beat everybody in the world who would
play him
so at this point
I will read the plaque as I go along of
each inductee
and then we'll gavel him in
Daniel Willard Fisk 1831 1904.
Daniel Willard Fisk was a major Pioneer
in chess organization journalism
literature and historical preservation
whose influence is still felt today he
originated the idea of the Nationwide
American chess Congress and helped to
make it a reality in 1857. American
chess star Paul Murphy
would have achieved would not have
achieved more than local Fame without
him
fisk's massive book on the event not
only gives the game of the Congress but
also deals with the creation of American
chess Association a precursor to today's
U.S chess and the author's important
role in standardizing the rules of Chess
he was also arguably the most
influential early U.S chess journalist
earning Renown through his magazine the
chess monthly and newspaper column in
the New York Saturday press
on behalf of the trustees of the U.S
chest trust and with the authority
granted to me I hereby induct Daniel
Willard Fisk into the U.S Chess Hall of
Fame
[Applause]
I spoke more about
Fisk because he wasn't able to represent
himself
our next inductee into the US Jess Hall
of Fame is James tarjan
and I guess Librarians are dominating
this segment of the proceedings because
James Sargent left chess to become a
librarian after earning the GM title and
playing in five straight olympiads and
several U.S championships
he even qualified for the world
championship cycle
competing in the 1979 Riga interzonal
but in 1984
he gave up chess completely
he swears he never played in the
tournament for 29 years
he gave up chess completely
to focus on being a librarian
29 years later he entered the U.S open
in Orlando and finished only half a
point out of first place
it wasn't long before he even defeated
former World Champ Vlad kramnik keep in
mind that when Jim quit chess
humans could still be computers
gratefully Jim is here with us tonight
and I will read his plaque
James tarjan born 1952
few have represented the United States
in chess olympias with greater
distinction than James tarjan he played
five times from 1974 to 1982 winning
four team one goal three blondes bronze
and three individual two gold and one
bronze medals his lifetime winning
percentage of 75.5 percent places him
equal second among Americans with Bobby
Fischer and Arthur date an active player
from 1965 to his 1984 retirement tarjan
returned to the game in 2014 with
spectacular results in 2017 he defeated
the world's former world champion
Vladimir krymech then ranked number
three in the world
at 2803 feeding on route to a rating
performance of 26.71 to date the best
ever result by an American player aged
65 or older
on behalf of the trustees
of the U.S Chester Austin with the
authority granted in me I hereby induct
James targin into the U.S Chess Hall of
Fame
[Applause]
come on tonight
okay hi hi everybody
I'm gonna try to make it short and sweet
um
obvious thing first it's I it's a great
thing for me to be here
there's a lot of water under the bridge
you know a lot of you folks are from two
generations after me I know some of some
of them
some of you folks go back with me
and um
especially those folks that go back with
me know what this means to me
um I thank all sorts of people the sink
felds of course for carrying the banner
of trust so well
um
I'm gonna
go back and
just mention
from long ago
um someone I hope they won't mind if I
call them their predecessors sent away
Peter gorski's Mrs P
who was
okay I was a kid
um
about 13 or 14.
um
over the hill by today's standards
already of course
as a chess prodigy
but our my folks moved into Los Angeles
and there was a chess club there the
Herman Steiner chess club which was
you know the Chess World was kind of
different in those days
it consisted primarily of old men like
me
in those days you'd go into the chess
club and I think it was true every lots
of places
and there'd be a bunch of old guys
playing chess
and the phone would ring and the guy
would answer it he
'd yell out to the other guy hey it's
your wife on the phone you know and he
the other guy would say tell her I'm on
the way home you know they were getting
the chess club was an escape for them
from their families and even maybe their
kids for a little while it's a little
hard to think of anybody
now going to the chess club to escape
kids
but that's the way it was in those days
and Mrs Peter Gorski though
had a vision
she wanted to expansion she wanted to
make one of her big things I think she's
most known for the big tournaments but
she wanted to bring you know young
people into chess so she
she started what she called a student
chess club
at the Steiner club which was only
Saturday mornings from ten to one
the old man
we're gonna have to put up with us
for those three hours and I don't think
they would have
I expect except Mrs P on the club
and you know they didn't have much
choice
so
she started that club I was one of the
younger people at 13.
and
we were supposed to leave about one
o'clock but anyway the rest is a lot of
water under the bridge
that I've seen now you go to a chess
tournament looks completely different in
a lot of ways better
you know you see the families there you
see all the kids there
um
and that's been a gradual thing I think
a really good thing
anyway
um I thank the just people who gave me
this honor it's a club that I very much
am proud to be a part of
and
um
they're gonna talk about my friend John
Watson next I wish he was here his
health wouldn't allow it
um
he's he admit we're study partners and
um
places best chess in his games with me
let me tell you that
okay thank you all thank you all very
much
[Applause]
Thanks James we will be able to hear
from John I believe right Emily we
actually do have a video in a minute so
we'll get to hear from him oh and you
know uh each inductee
gets this size
this size plaque
this is this is James plack James Tarzan
plaque
and uh in the hall
they're displayed this size
and also electronically if you haven't
seen that I represent most of you have
but if you haven't seen that you really
should go over and investigate how how
well they tell the history of chats
the next uh inductee is John Watson
uh John is a beloved figure he is noted
as a serious chess scholar
producing award-winning books translated
into many languages and producing
Championship students
he was our very first U.S national High
School champion
he showed another side and I remember
this quite well he showed another side
to us when he produced his hysterical
chess Man comic book series
John was educated as an engineer
in fact a little trivia
the next time you're driving along in a
valley
and you're talking on your cell phone
and your cell phone sticks with you and
doesn't drop the call
you can thank John and his partners
for developing and patenting
an algorithm that made that possible
so it's a multi-talented person
and
uh oh
if you're 75 you forget gambles thank
you thank you very much
so on behalf of the trustees of the U.S
trust trust and with the authority
granted to me
I hereby induct John Watson into the U.S
Chess Hall of Fame
[Applause]
[Music]
incredibly grateful for this honor and
especially delighted to be inducted with
Jim Tarzan who I've gotten there well
over the past few years and I admire
enormously
it's a bit overwhelming to be included
with all these great players many of
them Heroes of mine obviously my plane
achievements are not remotely comparable
to most others in the hall and I'm being
recognized for my other contributions to
chess particularly as a lifelong writer
and online contributor
I hope you can think of my selection as
representing chess writers everywhere so
let me say a few words about Chess
writing the lengthy tradition of Chess
Publications in the forms of books and
magazines form the basis of my own love
for chess as a child and it has
underpinned the popularity of Chess
throughout the game's existence
I think one thing I'd like to say that's
really worth saying about Chess writing
is that going back centuries it has
always been a labor of love
when I was younger all the Best Authors
worked for a fraction of the minimum
wage we researched and copied materials
by hand from libraries and personal
collections we spent hours upon hours
coming up with new ideas and analyzing
without engines or move checking we
laboriously typed corrected and retyped
manuscripts without word processing I
don't know if anybody remembers white
out
and we communicated and transferred
material back and forth by snail mail
so we sometimes took years to complete a
book I think especially at this point
I'm thinking about the best American
Writers like John Donaldson Jeremy
Selman and Andy soltis who lived in this
pre-cambrian world and of course there
were many others
um
today we've thankfully automated all of
these processes and what used to take
months now takes days I was therefore
able to write books and articles even
while being employed full times in
electrical engineer
but even now I think the majority of
Chess writing is still done mainly for
the love of it because authors want to
share the share their chess ideas and
stories
and there are also unexpected rewards
you're just writing one of the great
Joys is having people contact you or
come up to you at tournaments and tell
you how inspired they were by a book or
article that you wrote
I still get numerous emails from people
all over the world often with
suggestions in some theoretical
variation or other
okay so it's traditional at Hall of Fame
ceremonies to thank people for the
support and friendship that they've
given one over the years there are way
too many people to mention so I've
decided to limit myself to just a few of
my earliest influences and ones who have
not necessarily gotten full attention or
credit for their chess contributions
first I want to thank Reverend Howard
ellman a master at Nebraska state
champion he ran the Omaha Nebraska chess
club for years and he mentored me as an
inexperienced player driving me hundreds
of miles to play in my first rated
tournaments
the best player in my hometown Omaha in
those years was John Thomas
John was the only active local player
who knew about the latest chess
literature and theoretical ideas he
generously took the time to teach me
about Chess most importantly that there
was more to the game than simply
sacrificing all of your pieces in a mad
attempt to mate the king
John a university Professor became a
very strong master and never stopped
studying chess books while writing
articles and commentary about Chess
right up to this day
the most remarkable chess personality in
my journey was Chris Hendrickson who
gave to chassis in innumerable ways
including promoting women's chess
she got me started with teaching
organizing tournaments working with
school kids and volunteering for prison
chess programs among many other Pursuits
she also created and Drew the amazing
Chessman Comics upon which we
collaborated
Chris was beloved by all and one of a
kind
I owe a special thanks to Eric Schiller
who patiently and generously gave me of
his time and to guide me and many other
players I should say through the
intricacies of the new computer chess
world including both software and
Hardware long before it became user
friendly
America always found time to help people
with any issue that was frustrating them
he was well known nationally as an
organizer teacher and writer
finally thanks also to Sandra leonori
who guided me through the world of
online chess broadcasting also at a very
early stage of its development he helped
me to produce literally hundreds of
Chess interviews and lectures over the
years
and of course there are many other
people I could mention but I'll just
leave it at that thank you all for
listening and for continuing to support
this wonderful game of ours
[Music]
you know I don't want to shortchange
John so I want to read his plaque as
well
John Watson born in 1951. John Watson is
one of the greatest writers in the
history of American chess among the many
important books he has authored during
the past four decades are the
groundbreaking secrets of modern chess
strategy 2002 and chess strategy in
action 2003 he authored seminal works on
the English opening and French defense a
frequent contributed shelf life since
the 1970s Watson is well known for his
insightful book reviews he was a Pioneer
in early internet journalism with weekly
shows including chess talk with John
Watson for the internet chess club an
international Master Watson was the
first U.S national High School champion
and the U.S Championship excuse me U.S
Chess Championship participant he has a
lifetime of experience in chess teaching
and coaching and that brings us to the
end of the U.S Chess Hall of Fame
inductions
I should mention
that
Judith Polgar is one of the
inductees but is unable to make it
and so she will be inducted in a future
ceremony here
foreign
our first inductee is
for tonight is uh is someone who's
passed away and so I'll say a few extra
words because he's not here to speak for
himself and he has an amazing story
it's Miguel naidor
F was born in Warsaw and began playing
chess at 12.
traveled to Buenos Aires in 1939 with
the Polish national team for a
tournament two weeks after he arrived
Germany invaded Poland
he was unable to return safely to his
family
who was Jewish
and stayed in Argentina
he thereby escaped the Holocaust but he
lost his wife
child
father
mother
and four brothers in concentration camps
just want to tell one story about how he
remembered them
in the 1940s Mr nador naidorf Excuse me
gave an exhibition of blindfold play or
play without the side of the board
he took on 45 players at one time
carrying
all the games simultaneously in his head
he won 39 Drew four lost two
in 1972 he recalled in an interview why
he did this
I did this not as a stunt
I hope that this exhibition
would be reported throughout Germany
Poland and Russia and that some of my
family might read about it and get in
touch with me
but none did so
he became an Argentine citizen in 1944
and went on to be a leading tournament
contender
I will read his plaque
Miguel nidor from 1910 1997.
Miguel nidorf whose name is associated
with one of the most famous openings in
chess was one of the top players in the
world in the 1940s and 1950s born in
Poland he settled in Argentina after
playing in the 1939 Buenos Aires chess
Olympiad he was also one of the most
successful performers in Olympiad
history winning 17 for silver and three
bronze and four individual medals three
gold and one silver in 14 competitions
over four decades
in 1947 he faced 45 opponents in
blindfold chess setting a record that
stood until 2011.
thank you
on behalf of fide the international
Chess Federation and with the authority
granted to me I hereby induct Miguel
neidor into the World Chess Hall of Fame
[Applause]
and finally tonight we have
A well-earned induction into the World
Chess Hall of Fame
Grand Master Eugene Torrey
Eugene tells me that chess was very much
a family affair
in fact he once played in a team
competition with the six brothers and
his fan as team members and his father
as Captain
in 1974 at 22 years old
Tory became the first Asian to earn the
GM title it was one of many first
he beat reigning world champion Anatoly
karapov in a game that's part that's
become part of Filipino chess history
now we'll read his plaque
Eugene Torrey born in 1951. Philippine
Grandmaster Eugene Torrey has been a
Trailblazer for Asian Chefs for half a
century achieving a number of
Continental Milestones including first
Grand Master in 1974. first to defeat a
reigning world champion and Natalie
karpov in 1976 and first to reach the
candidate stage of the world
championship 1982-1983.
a member of the Philippine Olympia team
a record 23 times Tori won three
individual medals on board one silver at
nice 1974 and bronze at Malta 1980 and
Dubai 1986. he also won a bronze medal
on board three at Baku 2016 at the age
of 64.
Tori was the official second of Bobby
Fischer in his 1992 rematch with Boris
spassky
on behalf of fide the international
Chess Federation and with the authority
granted to me I hereby induct Eugene
Torrey into the World Chess Hall of Fame
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to Mr Rex and Mrs Jenny singfield
the benefactor and host of this event
to my fellow co-inductis and to all
chess lovers who are here today
this is my first time to be in the chess
capital of the world
and it is with great honor to be among
the distinguished people who are
gathered here today
chess has been an incredible blessings
in my life
providing me with cherished memories and
experiences that will remain with me
forever
all the world champions including those
who were active in the game before I was
born became part of my life
through their classical books and
Immortal games
I had the privilege of sharing memorable
times with some of them
one such experience was with my good
friend Bobby Fisher
who
finalized the rules of his invention
while we were together
in Hungary
three years later we went to Buenos
Aires
for the first public demonstration of
Bobby's fishy random
it is no exaggeration that when you are
dealing with Bobby
many unexpected things could happen
without going into all the details
the projected fish random match between
the champion of Argentina and myself was
aborted
although we did not become part of
History
I'm happy to mention that my Countryman
Grandmaster Wesley saw is the first and
reigning fishy random world champion
my induction to the World Chess Hall of
Fame is the defining moment of my chess
career and is an affirmative validation
of the profession I chose to pursue and
that my passion purchase would
ultimately result in significant
achievement and now by being an inducted
to the Hall of Fame becomes a genuine
source of Pride and honor an Accolade I
wish to share with my family my country
and my fellow chess players throughout
the world the Asians in particular
I wish to convey my gratitude to various
individuals and organizations my humble
achievements in chess would not have
been possible without the moral support
encouraging influence and material
contributions of the many people and
various organizations to whom I was
fortunately connected
my sincere and heartfelt gratitude is
owed first and foremost to my creator
for the gift of life and talent
to Mr Rex and Mrs Janine Janine
singer siegfeld many factors of the
Chess Hall of Fame events chess is very
fortunate to have your genuine love and
support for the game thank you very much
[Applause]
for bringing all chess federations and
players harmoniously together with this
special thanks to former president
florencio campomones whose contribution
in promoting chess I personally
witnessed
it is still Vivid to me when after our
Maiden friendship match with China in
1975
he whispered to me this prophetic words
we have just awakened a sleeping giant
I can further attest to the great
success of fide in promoting chess
worldwide because the Olympiad went from
60 participating teams in my first
Olympiad in 1970
288 teams in 2022
the word Junior went from being held
every two years to becoming a yearly
competition then the all-important age
group events and many more official
video tournaments were introduced and
the interest in chess multiplied with
the Advent of computer chess
but for Fida to achieve such a great
stride it needed the Helping Hand of all
sectors encompassing the support of the
government and private sectors
exactly what is being exemplified here
in Saint Louis
with the backing of a course of the
national federations it was this kind of
partnership that helped fide achieve its
objective of popularizing Chess
worldwide
thank you to all the organizers and
sponsors of all the local and
international tournaments especially the
ones I have played to starting in the
late 60s and up to the present
during the 70s it was practically
impossible for an Asian to become a
grand master unless he campaigns for the
title in an International Tournament in
Europe
actually there were tournaments we were
together with my friend
James tarjan
also my gratitude to the Philippine
government for supporting various
international events such as the 1978
World Championship held in Baguio in the
1992 World Chess Olympiad in Manila
to my chest Federation which supports me
and continues to promote chess in our
country to my parents for providing all
the support that guided me in the right
direction and to my siblings
for the much needed practice during my
formative years when tournaments were a
rarity
to Bobby Fisher the great friendship we
shared and his trust in me as he second
in the 1992 World Championship match
with Boris ispassky
to all the chess colleagues I have
encountered on the board and to my chest
funds for their unwavering support to my
many patrons and sponsors both in the
government and private sectors and last
but not the least
to my
wife
The Wind Beneath My Wings
my
thank you Marlene my tribal companion
and source of inspiration and to my only
child Nicole and my grandchildren who
made my life complete
I would also like to congratulate all my
co in that peace sharing the Accolade
with you is truly an honor again a
million thanks to the hosts and
organizers aboard chest Hall of Fame
especially to Mr and Mrs Singh sing sing
a film
in closing I would like to share that it
has greatly benefited me to apply what
I've learned in chess to my everyday
life and that is to always protect and
promote our mental King physical king
and the most important of all our
spiritual King thank you very much
everyone thank you
[Applause]
well it's hard to follow that Eugene
Tori truly is a legend in the game of
chess James targe and Miguel naidorf all
of our inductees tonight another round
of applause for them
[Applause]
so I promise we'll be done very soon
this is the last phase of the opening
ceremony and it's the one that the
players care about the most this is the
drawing of lots we do the drawing of
Lodge to determine the order in which
the players will face each other and
with which colors they will play
to do the honors uh it's my privilege to
be joined on the stage now by the chief
Arbiter of the 2022 U.S Championship
Frank Guadalupe
foreign
first I'd like to say that uh this is I
believe my seventh U.S Championship the
first one was in 2006 in Saint Louis
and since the Inception as he has been
said many times in 2009 in St Louis for
the event I have been here six times so
I I love the city I love the chess club
obviously Maryland Avenue there is
magnificent I tell my friends about it
who hasn't been in San Luis I love to
walk every day in Forest Park uh maybe
five miles today
but I came here at the invitation of uh
Tony and joy uh thank you so much I'm
very humble and thankful that you have
invited me again
of course my thanks to Rex Ms Genie for
putting up such a wonderful event here
as many have said already
um so at first the players we had a
players meeting earlier today or before
getting here not too far from here at
the U.S chess a new office
um so we went over all the details uh
for the rest of the audience all I have
to say is as you know I'm sure we're
going to have uh 14 uh players in the US
championship and 14 players in the U.S
Women's Championship so in in all we'll
have 13 games
between tomorrow and the 19th they'll
have two days off Monday the 10th of
October and Sunday the 16th of October
and if need be
will have a playoff on the 20th if
there's a tie in either Championship or
both we'll have to play up on the 20th
so uh the game Star obviously you know
at one o'clock in the afternoon
uh and the rest again I cover or we
covered during the players meetings so
now what remains is to do the join of
the locks and I would like uh Chris bird
who is the chief of the Women's
Championship to join me here Chris
and of course he's not going to join us
here but I will I'd like to acknowledge
uh International Arbiter uh or I'm sorry
feed the Arbiter working on
International Avatar Enrique Huerta so
he's our Deputy for both events so Chris
and I believe that uh Tony is going to
call the players and uh Chris and I are
going to take turns uh doing the join of
the lots for the players so Tony all
yours
okay to celebrate the fact that we're
here at the St Louis aquarium in Union
Station uh we have some very lovely
gifts for the players this year they are
stuffed otters and stuffed sharks if you
want to see the real thing by the way
the Otters are over here the sharks are
just around the corner there I swear the
shark exhibit is totally cool definitely
worth looking at
thank you
okay starting with the U.S Women's
Championship the defending Champion is
not here this year Carissa Yip so we
will go in raiding order we start with
Grand Master Irina Crush
the ladies will be drawing from the
otters
the U.S Championship will be drawing
from the sharks
and if you would when you come to draw
your number please come up on stage back
here by Chris and Frank and that way we
can get some great photos of the front
of you
and I'm sorry what did I really draw
pairing number 13.
next up International Master Anna
zatonski
gotta go the Long Way Anna sorry
in the meantime I can tell you one of
the very first U.S women's championships
when Anna was in St Louis uh I asked her
to show me some chess puzzles and that
was a big mistake you know she showed me
these puzzles some of them were easy and
really fun and I think I'm still trying
to solve some of them
Anna's otter
sorry Chris number one
next up ashritha es will run
ashrifa approaches the table
carefully considers her options
and chooses pairing number five
next up
International Master Nazi pikizi
I guess I could fill the dead air Nazi
pakizi is a two-time U.S women's
champion
oh I don't know what the rest said now
number 12 for Nazi next up women's
Grandmaster begum Tokyo Nova
Beckham chooses period number six
foreign
comes on the stage
picks her otter
and it's number two
next up the 2022 U.S girls junior
Champion women Grandmaster Jennifer you
thank you
Jennifer picks her otter
strummy
number 14. she doesn't want to show me
next up the youngest competitor in the
U.S Women's Championship v-day Master
Alex Lee
thank you
Alice has pairing number 10.
next v-day Master Rue Yang Yang
three young approaches the stage chooses
otter number
eight
next women's Grandmaster Sabina foyger
Sabina chooses pairing number three
next up women's Grandmaster Talia
Cervantes
so you guys may notice by the way we
have 14 players in the the two events
this year and normally we do 12 players
we plan to keep the US championship in
the fall in order to catch up we had an
extra U.S junior and U.S Open qualifier
for the US championship and then
likewise for the women's section and
Talia chooses pairing number seven
next up women's International Master
Megan Lee
Megan choose his otter number four
next up women's International Master
Rochelle Wu
so we've got 11 and 9 left hopefully one
of those yeah
Michelle number 11.
and last but certainly not least women's
feet a master Sophie Morris Suzuki
foreign
Ty played an amazing playoff in the U.S
girls junior Championship just narrowly
missing out this year
so if he has pairing number nine
so to announce the round one pairings in
the U.S Women's Championship section
tomorrow starting at 1 30 the broadcast
is delayed by 30 minutes the broadcast
will begin at 1 30. pairings are Anna
satonski versus Jennifer Yu tatev
abrahamian versus Irena Crush Sabina
foyer versus Nazi pikizi Megan Lee
versus Rochelle Wu ashrita s waran
versus Alice Lee begum Tokyo Nova versus
Sophie Morris Suzuki and and Talia
Cervantes versus Ru Yang Yan all right
now we move on to the U.S Championship
section and we'll begin with the
defending U.S Champion Grand Master
Wesley so
[Applause]
[Music]
Wesley picks his shark
and he's shark number 12.
next up we have Grandmaster Fabiano
caruana
[Music]
it's a great new podcast by the way if
you haven't checked it out tune in to c
squared pretty good
I haven't met a guest yet but I'm hoping
to get invited one day he has pairing
number seven
next Grand Master Lavon aronian playing
in his first U.S championship
[Applause]
s
14.
makes it easy
next Grand Master lenier Dominguez
[Music]
by the way I don't know if you guys
realize but a lot of these folks live in
St Louis Favi Lanier
uh Ray Robinson Darius speards
uh who am I forgetting oh I'm sorry
lavonaronian he's pretty good too of
course Talia Cervantes
sorry I wasn't paying attention number
eight thanks
next up Grandmaster Sam Shanklin
expedited approach Sam picks
number six
[Music]
next we have Grand Master Jeffrey Zhang
[Music]
and I guess we still like even though
you live in Texas
[Music]
Jeffrey chooses pairing number five
next we have Grand Master Sam sethian
[Music]
s
Sam picks number two
[Music]
next up Grand Master Hans Neiman
[Music]
foreign
stinks about it
Perry number 11.
next Grand Master Ray Robson oh I'm
sorry Ray I forgot you and my St Louis
residence
did I okay
[Music]
spray picks
pairing number nine
next up Grandmaster Darius spearts
[Applause]
[Music]
Darrow picks number 10.
next Grandmaster Alex Linderman
[Music]
foreign
number one
next the 2022 U.S junior Champion
Christopher you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christopher is pairing number four
next the 2022 US Open Champion Alshon
more diabadi
we have 3 and 13 left so let's see
which he gets
while Sean chooses pairing number 13.
and just to keep us honest the wild card
from the event Grandmaster or wonder
Liang
[Music]
pairing number three
so to announce the round one pairings in
the U.S Championship we have Alex
Lenderman versus Lavon aronian Sam
sethian versus elshon mordiabadi a
Wonder Liang vs Wesley so Christopher
you versus Hans Neiman Jeffrey Zhang vs
Darius spearts Sam Shanklin versus Ray
Robson and Fabiano caruana versus
leniere Dominguez once again I want to
thank you all from the bottom of our
heart at the St Louis chess club at the
World Chess Hall of Fame we work hard to
make chess as good as we can and thank
you for helping us do it I hope you have
a great night and don't forget to tune
in tomorrow at 1 30 at uschesschamps.com
for all the action thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]